guess what I am added internet trolls I
get what they're doing
I mean comedians or society trolls
that's what we are I mean for comedians
to be mad at internet trolls it's just
that there's just no technique there's
no there's no like there's no skill I
remember when I first read the script
for workaholics for the audition I
remember reading that just thinking oh
this is never gonna get on the air like
I thought to myself are they really
gonna let someone say these particular
things on TV I had no idea
like even in the pilot like the first
joke then this is in the presentation as
well as the whole like order of how you
should do a dick pic how it causes a
nipple dick [ __ ] butthole and we're
just like there's no way we can do this
week a lot of people came in an audition
for month oh yeah it was dude - dude I
know all these people it was like and
then another thing - about it you didn't
know what you wanted there was Latino
guys right it was black guys it was like
it was I didn't know what they wanted
and I remember walking in the room for
the first time and I saw all of I saw
first I saw Adam and I was doing here
cuz you know knew Adam right I knew him
so I didn't know like I was like oh this
is cute Adams in here laughs I'm a
business you know I'm a Clippers fan I
got season tickets with Adam I know hey
don't hate what it is but yeah I
remember running into you in our little
snack room and I don't know you were
kind of like oh man I'm a day early or
whatever it was like you were like no
cuz you said to me you were like are you
here for Montez and I was like yeah yeah
you were like that's tomorrow yes and
then I was so embarrassed at the town's
like well yeah oh you know in my mind
I'm thinking I'm just here scouting you
know before I well see but me I had that
small interaction with you and I ran
back to the writers room and I basically
was like guys I just met our Montez
whatever you know you wrote that first
episode right that I was in I'm credited
I mean all the episodes we
together and then they kind of like draw
names out of hats to assign who gets
what episode and mine just so I
technically own your character oh
because I wrote that episode that [ __ ]
was chaos by the way the final season oh
dude yeah it just was like it was didn't
it was insane but I remember you then
when I watched the show I'm like hell
yeah dude this guy was taking some trips
to work [ __ ] that you did have to work
on yeah like I holux like I'm saying
like we knew everybody's comedic angle
and where they would come in and that's
why we stopped it you know we had [ __ ]
around with it so much we had made ders
the crazy one yeah made Blake the
straight one we've tried to contain Adam
yeah
but Adam ended up work you know it was
like it's like we just made you feel
like it ran its course we knew it it
without like completely recycling it
it's like what else are we gonna do what
other drug can we take none of us have
even taken [ __ ] peyote but we're like
saying it's cool
yeah like if comi central one guys still
be doing it today I mean [ __ ] yeah I
always wanted a diverse cast as well a
we're bringing three white guys to the
table so you gotta you come with
foundation you gotta switch it up a
little bit but I know like with the
character of Montez yeah we kind of
wanted someone who you know it was kind
of just an odd person we wanted
everybody in the office to be kind of
real and when you artwork in those kind
of places you meet the weirdest people
yeah so we kind of just can't new that
we want him to be sort of a tech nerd
yeah I felt like I was the leader of the
Nerds and that are the weird guys and
that when that crew especially when I
first met Jett said in Weymouth yeah wow
that's a far back way he's know from the
very beginning oh man like day one
Wayman was day one damn I didn't know
this this is great inside workaholics
information and it will wane
day one alright what I wanted one of the
things I wanted to ask you about about
workaholics do you think that because
it's such a dude show you know was such
a like about drinking and all that kind
of stuff and you know women
tits and all that do you think of
workaholics could have survived in the
climate now um I think that the people
involved in that show us you know we're
smart enough to make it work we would
have found a way to make it work into
some of the air I think that I think it
were colics would still be on the air
what would you have wanted to do that
though cuz this would have been like the
tenth season would you have wanted to
get to ten or that a certain point you
were like I got to go on and do
something else well one thing was what
for a while we were chasing that like
syndication number and then stupidly
we'd never even realized that Congress
and rule doesn't syndicate so really
just you setting your own bar like well
how long do you want to go all right
when it was time for workaholics and you
guys you you were ready to create it on
your own is that this Dart isn't that
right isn't it like you guys you guys
made to pilot yourself in a sense yeah
the original pilot the original pilot
which was all date so basically we were
doing all that stuff the thing that hit
was our most low concept workaholics you
know what I mean like we had [ __ ]
rapid Wizards it was just like so up
there they're like you don't give us the
office comedy that that one we do we
stammers in an office we like that one
which is why we have a whole bunch of
episodes that push the envelope because
we want to do that high-concept crazy
[ __ ] but the thing that was the most
relatable was just the most low concept
[ __ ] we could think of dudes and a house
dudes in the office speaking our
language yeah
Kyle hits me he's like hey hey man I got
a part be in this movie and I'm like I'm
ready to go and you go well hold on a
second I had to make sure and manage
your expectations let me tell you what
this part is so you wanted me to come on
go get my ass eaten
this is the big thing you said it's not
funny you're seen in the movie that was
your sales pitch yeah well it is it's
hilarious that why didn't you do it I
don't know oh really I my you didn't
want your ass eaten on screen well how
dare you
yes I thought that this the character's
name was husky hostage
oh okay then why ask first of all this
is the first I'm hearing that his
nameless husky either always ready I
mean we made the script when it was when
we were doing workaholics oh you always
knew the leading drug I couldn't get a
bigger part I couldn't be a cop I
couldn't be an FBI agent told me I'd be
the guy you totally could have been a
cop but I saved the cop
I saved the cut for the next movie am i
right I felt like you guys were trying
to torture me it wasn't so bad I mean
there was an episode where I had to eat
boogers and I I learned real butter he
doesn't matter but I specifically
remember you coming here to be talking
about like a way to eat okay I mean I
like to see you squirm but but now kids
just watch like unboxing videos you ever
seen that [ __ ] it's ridiculous it and
then you see they have like 6 million
views of just like a little kid opening
up a doll I don't know what it is doing
to these kids mind but it there
they love it he's hypnotizing you
haven't got hypnotized you haven't just
had a video on like that and unlike I've
been watching this for 25o their voices
are always the worst I hate their
cadence I hate the words they use I hate
the way they say it's like it's always
terrible like oh my god oh yeah it's a
like a adult babies childish yeah we are
we're gonna play destiny
let's take it to destiny because I can't
even when I'm not even yelling I can't
play video games around my girlfriend
when I'm just being like damn it it's
6:30 in the morning right on a Wednesday
morning Wednesday we haven't slept
haven't slept we're trying to be quad
wrong yeah you know in prison of elders
yes destiny mm-hmm I'm screaming we
don't play no more no play no more from
2007 know one time I was at his house
and I won mm-hm and he I look at him he
looks at me and he just goes oh no no I
know I didn't punch you like that I
punched you like no yeah pop I would rap
like as hard as he could like again you
know like the age dude yeah but you know
what though I get it though because
you're a sore winner well I went to one
football tryout yeah I went to one
football tryout the ball hit me in two
fingers just it yeah yeah it was late
and I was like I'm out two things the
ball hit me in two fingers and the coach
yelled at me because I I you know I get
to run a route and drop the ball three
times in a row on the third time I I
went like this whoa yeah and then the
fourth time I jammed my finger and I was
like I'm out cuz it is kind of crazy
that they just let like kids throw away
because their accuracy is not there at
all they're terrible a hundred we saw
this weekend go ahead we're in the
backyard it was perfect where was it at
it was over at Studio City was perfect
and
you got like the only thing he didn't
know I had animal the only thing is
there's these three hawks I go oh
they'll pick off the cats what is this
as a sidenote yeah oh this is doom Hawks
This Is England
way tonight your school The Improv kids
were the bullies you guys were like that
this is like we're and [ __ ] you would
yeah we an we're and [ __ ] devil Mountain
improv Lee what's up champions you guys
are divas
yeah especially towards the later
seasons you just need to know it all
right
dete house oh how neat that what was
deep yeah come on know what your office
you didn't set sign have you been on
sets yes we are now that I realized what
I went on other steps out
we wall where the D bicycles are gonna
come back the Spice Girls are back this
is the game and this is big in the game
is this is this is big when I I think
that all the news is like it's like it's
generated based on my interest right how
come on all the news sources like a ton
into Twitter it's all Spice Girls okay
it's like I said on CNN Spice Girls
could be on there now why are Spice
Girls so important to you well they're
like the first music I remember like you
when I was a little kid okay alright so
Spice Girls are big the Spice Girls are
back I did not know that so thank you
for that news yeah well besides they all
look old as [ __ ] and they don't have to
dress themselves totally flattering at
all sleepy dumpy-dumpy
know which ones dumpy don't be a spice
girl they alternate dumpy yeah it
wouldn't be hot mess for Fox at like 9
a.m. in the morning and I know that I'm
auditioning is between me and Taran
Killam oh god right
we shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up so
we're play knock off camera and you see
I win if not that mode I just win and my
brother goes oh yeah he goes to the
kitchen we were living together uh-huh
he takes two knives not butter knives a
rough days you've got like steak knife -
steak knives right and he starts no no I
had him behind my back yeah well you
know I couldn't but I saw you take them
what were you that with that move they
don't know is there part what's your
wood then with what's your face what's
your favorite did you have like a top
three do you have like a three that you
go these are the ones that I'll always
remember
oh just all a blur oh I mean it's pretty
much a blur but though I really like
business trip
the one where we like take acid and go
with Mary Beth - like seal the deal was
in there episode yeah you weren't but
that one was that one was cool I really
like that I really loved of what is the
name I think it's called good morning
the one where homegirl dies and she has
the wake at the oh my god really love
that I you know what I always tell
people they don't know that when an
extra can be so annoying that the
creators create a write an episode where
they kill her well that's what was cool
about our show is like if you kind of
just didn't invite her back to be in the
background people probably wouldn't even
in the notice I know but you guys like
not a skill right we gotta write a whole
episode around I'm not necessarily a fan
improv not an improv am like if people
are just doing raw love improv but oh I
can see it can be really bad it can't be
it see yeah there's no middle ground
improv is like a child actor
they're either great yeah or Anakin
Skywalker yeah you're me wait those are
both great oh no come on baby
you kid Manta meadows
that's my [ __ ] do you like and if you
like he was the worst the [ __ ]
podracer scene is I'll take that over
like half more than half of what Star
Wars franchise puts out now okay well I
want the [ __ ] podraces I I'll
just listen to the pod racing sounds
that's how dope it was like that was
sound revolutionary insane yeah
the Star Wars universe without
[ __ ] Jar Jar Binks okay that's
the homie right there larders you've got
some glass yeah but let me ask you this
but can you without weed
would you feel the same way well now
what makes you think that we to
influence that decision in any way I
will say though Jar Jar probably smokes
big blocks
Jar Jar sighs blah see they could if
they just added weed to charge our
storyline he'd be like the number one
care if he was just always like they
would make it all set on you all to like
you know what you should do you gotta go
see stuff alive I mean it really changes
it just gives you like it's such a
euphoric feeling it's such like you know
you feel like you're a part of something
I suggest you go see your favorite
comedians go see your favorite music
artists go to a concert man those things
stay with you forever but if you can
make them all rated-r which I think of
what they should be sure I think if the
you know that's the problem what I
believe it's like it's like when you
first all Logan Logan was crazy when you
when I first saw Logan and I saw those
claws go through that guy's head and to
begin the movie I thought oh [ __ ] yeah
this is why they haven't ever shown this
because that is elusive you know like
it's like that's what that really would
look like right you know but yeah but
I'll tell you what he did for my
birthday know
one day he goes BAM I got your present
he comes over and I go what is it and he
goes like this it's two tickets to a
movie alright so I'm sitting here he is
exactly like this but next to my brother
yeah yeah you're next to my brother is
probably a 50 year old lady no she was
about 30 no we don't know it's dark so
the people next to you did what
so we were laughing and I lady next to
him you want like this she went yeah
like that's why yeah I like this
yeah like that to him all right now
check this out he had steak no reason
yeah
all right you're on an island yeah okay
you know you're gonna be on an island
you're gonna be for six months what's
the five movies you have to have with
you for your downtime movie for me it's
the Godfather like I would need one and
two would be part of my thing those are
great now the way that I'm want the
matrix
I'd grab okay School of Rock and that's
funny
yeah those would be like those are like
over actually great movie yeah I can
watch School of Rock like any time of
day I did I just had just put it on I
think I would grab the labyrinth of
course just because I named it just
because I needed it's in my soul see I
want to pull a ninja turtles into it too
oh so you just okay you're you you're
always gonna your your side are you
sci-fi you just no no Ninja Turtles like
maybe the first one but that's just
inferred nostalgic I think that's for
but a lot of my core values came from
there two of brotherhood and friendship
like about what you're saying right now
is that because I find that people that
are like let's say you're a sound person
right mm-hmm you can't watch a movie
without a guy this sound sucks
I can feel a lighting person you're like
every time you know why they like it
like that mm-hmm
no as a director do you find yourself
having trouble sometimes watching things
if you go like why do they make that
[ __ ] choice oh yeah so is this why
then when you're thinking about the
movies that you like it's kind of
mindless kind of just like you know
these are just fun I can you could
divorce yourself of that thought process
I love entertainment for entertainment
that's good I don't don't ever lose
no that's my favorite thing like the
worst movie in the last 10 years now
what do you think it is that like a
movie that was so hyped up oh it was a
cultural movie that just was the worst
and I have I know what it is know the
last Jedi oh yeah
I have one worse than that what solo was
way worse that was because could I say
no it was all way worse hockey how you
gonna get a guy who looks like he's
older than Harrison Ford was I ain't
agreeing you know it looks like tears
before the father he's just not a good
look in know Morse no more I'm like
we're done with it
nobody deal with Luke dude come on man
this is Luke Skywalker you can't just
have him on this remote island and then
have him and then it didn't show any of
the training that he did for you know
how she learning these intricate Jedi
lightsaber moves on her own now you know
what I'm saying it's like dude show dude
that's second-worst in front Empire
Strikes Back
it shows Yoda actually training Luke you
know with the all the guys right right
they cut you to Baca best friend I
better see your face your hairy face in
tears like just wet like a dog that went
into a swimming book like specifically
Jedi's okay yeah there's a hierarchy
when you say you start as a Padawan this
the you know schooling right like like
belts like velcro you know what I mean -
your second
I love Flynn I love lip but now everyone
gets ahold knows how to do that stuff
that's from force awaken that's a Jedi
that's true so now the whole little hold
on Star Wars and Return of the Jedi the
movie is all centered around a huge plan
to blow up this high-tech not
technological of a machine right so now
they sneak in the back door
okay well they sneak in the back door
happens to be a high-level captain
walking around the back door she goes to
a random terminal and takes the shields
down you mean to tell me nobody in
Mission Control can be like yo uh the
shields are down put it back up this is
the Death Star who's the [ __ ] dark so
I got him a job if it can't be improv
three days later
four days later I'm sorry four days
later Bob I got fired
tell the proper story yeah I was a food
runner there huh and so my job I had a
like Carrie super nachos and doing
whatever they ordered in between the
shows right in the dark so you had him
like you know I mean like but like with
like everyone else had to do that too
yeah it's not like you had only a
specific place blond girl I forgot her
name she put an order wrong no green
onions or something oh you are attacking
a female no no no let me explain myself
man so I like so I like they set that
sent the order back and then they're
complaining and then all I did was I
went up to her lets her name was
bringing I don't know if her name was
Brittany I hey Brittany next time you
make sure on the computer not I've just
didn't put no green onions oh like that
yeah I get my job at sushi Dan right two
days later he gets fired why he talked
to the sushi head sushi chef
inappropriately so I'm going to say
something right now all right I need
help with this one can I defend myself
okay I'm uh I worked the noon shift and
I'm a food runner again here's what we
know you're not and so I took a order
with the sushi orders you have to get it
directly from the sushi chef then he'll
go okay Table three Table eight table or
whatever uh-huh
so this this cream dude from Salt
whatever he was like yeah he WA table
you three you talking to me like I'm in
the middle
like I'm like the rookie in the median
I'm saying and so I went up to him I go
hey man you can't talk to me like I just
want to say Steve in these three
examples there's a moment where you feel
disrespected yeah and you react right
yeah okay and so no I go hey man you
can't talk to me like that yeah we're
not in Korea dude lean on me now is
there a moment you could say to yourself
though
that you are being disrespected and you
were in a unit in the right but is there
a moment that you can say to yourself if
I had to handle it differently I would
have you know in through counseling now
and through my therapy I would have
handled it differently yeah see I'm see
personal growth right here yeah like I
said I don't think there's anything
wrong with meeting some money online
make that the initial thing that's the
the introduction the hey how you doing
like your pictures chat a little bit but
then immediately get off of that give
them your number get their number make
plans go do something go sit down for
coffee sit across from a person and
really talk to them look in their eyes
do you know how different it is like I
don't care how close or romantic you
think you are if you're just texting
that is not real communication you lose
the nuance of what somebody is saying
their body language you're not as brave
you have to like actually be thoughtful
and think about what you're saying
before you say things to people but this
is how we're communicating now this is
what we're doing everybody's chatting
and talking online and talking through
snapchat and Twitter and Instagram and
texting that's not real communication
yeah my first first real director yeah
you know I'm your Marty Scorsese yeah
you're the first one like you know and
then by the you know by season seven it
was like you know you know we had like
two takes and it was like moving on you
know town right now in LA and it's the
Aquaman you know I'm not why does it
look like it I am not watching that yeah
but every woman's blond hair
watching Aquaman no but at the same time
though you have to remember that when
these things were first created we're
much more racist country if you miss
lane what if Bruce Wayne was Indian
would you watch it probably depending on
you know he would throw you off the hole
you wouldn't be able to get past the
idea that she's not Indian well I don't
know it's a fictional character I
understand it but stay true that's what
that's why right when you someone like
that when the last M ever and ever and
airbender comes out you think yourself
finally we know we get to see it because
you know alright alright let me know we
get to see us okay well let me let me
tell you the war I'm we sure the
difference in my mind if there's a rich
billionaire in he's Indian and he
decides to be Batman I'm fine with that
okay because because and his name is
Bruce Wayne the whole story it could be
you know whatever what would you change
these American you know cuz this man has
pre he's third-generation Indian
American and they're billionaires he
became Batman my problem while I'm with
you with this Airbender thing is he
seemed to be doing stuff that there
should be Asian people here yeah you
know you're at a monastery there rather
like a yeah they're talking about fufu
like you know Buddhist type stuff and so
then you you can't do that you know why
right so I'm saying if there's a show
about like you're at a sushi restaurant
and then the chef is Indian there then I
might be like well why that guy Indian
but I see what yourself you know the
meat yeah yeah so you know the same
problem that you have a bit about that
Disney movie the beauty in the penis
right same thing where you they go into
those I never saw the movie but yeah
they're in a 14th century French town
and there's six random black people in
this you can't just do that yeah right
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense right so you're looking
at you like houses how how are they
there yeah so that's what I'm saying
about that's why I'm not it's not the
same to me like look like a Superman
if Will Smith was playing Superman yeah
like yeah there could be black people on
Krypton like they did you just change
the story you know and trust me I don't
like being force-fed Asians either
alright like when I'm watching Star Wars
yeah
too many I know I see what you're doing
isn't it like I want like Charlie's
Angels I want to you [ __ ] wife okay
yeah how's that house being a father is
it is it changed your perspective on on
like what you do or is it like get more
focus like what are you know what is all
the cliches that people say about having
a kid are you what are you excited about
it was interesting because like you know
go from game over man a super
boundary-pushing who gives a [ __ ] kind
of attitude it to a Sandler movie that
is a little bit more broader I'm not
sipping as much haterade on on the broad
stuff you know I think I used to sip a
lot of em yeah area one on like this
[ __ ] that's like it's fine
what do you mean cuz it has good values
and stuff it's right it's bad no I kind
of want that [ __ ] to go into my son's
brain to getting out you know swish
Twitter would do a thing where they
delete tweets you know like after six
months you you know delete my history
and let's move on from there cuz you
know I'm different now boom I want to
clear that out cuz like I have and I
know I've tweeted some stuff like
sometimes Twitter's just like a you you
say like whatever you're you feeling
something you like I can't believe that
happen you go boom and then like people
are holding you to that
it's one moment did you know about him
and you know even though what we're
doing when we're standing right the way
you know we're putting your head touched
his head know where our heads are like
this and we're wrestling and I'm like
rubbing it like you know an Indian you
know like an Indian rub my head on his
head so your head is touching his head
yeah but he's touching mine as well it's
mutual but who instigated the head type
it doesn't know we were doing it you
know we're locking up like my brother
just goes and he threw me know I shocked
him you shocked me I didn't throw a
shock me and I was out the window then
he flew out the window shard the glass
on my body that was out the window like
this you're ever gonna catch your hair
is that ever gonna be a thing where you
gonna be like would you what role would
you cut your hair for or who what would
the circumstances be like is I got to
beat Spielberg there's got to be like
you know who is a really like Spielberg
would work with me
I don't I don't know I feel like I have
to go like mullet with bangs before I go
fully or I just want to shave it will
you shave your my baguette every single
to this will you shave your mustache and
I always say you wouldn't want me to
shave yeah I would look ridiculous right
we'd record store would be really cool
but a weave movie theater yeah all in
this snack place would just be off the
chain you'd have to have a waitress just
walking around that's a really good idea
yeah with hot dogs and people would just
be like it would be nonstop be like I'm
seeing dr. strange again she's three
times today gets better every time
people just don't leave the Peters what
would happen yeah that that's the
problem